yeah you don't want quick tip for a
prospective babysitter's if you show up
and turns out you're not actually
watching a kid run inside number nine
episode six of series one the finale of
series one and for at least the
foreseeable future the last one of these
that I'm going to do a individual review
on I do plan to keep watching the show I
probably won't do episode by episode
reviews I might if like I feel a really
particular need I have to talk about any
given episode but that's the plan right
now anyways this is the heroine and this
is an episode that a lot of people seem
to not have much affection for judging
by my own comment section at the very
least so what can I say about this well
it's that mysteric he goes hard in on
the on the gothic horror angle there is
absolutely no doubt about that premise
wise in case you're watching this Vahine
the thing I don't know why you would be
just in case we have a teenage girl show
you know this is obviously all set in
London showing up at a very old house
that is in a cellular dead zone that she
she's booked for a babysitting gig and
she gets there and she's not really
watching a baby she's just watching a
house as these two siblings who live
there
you know head out for an evening and
leave the house with just her and their
older
disabled sibling who is confined to his
room alone in the house and it is as
creepy and atmospheric as that setup
requires there's never any doubt that
this is a bad situation that's sort of
the nature of gothic horror because when
you're doing different stripes of horror
you approach it in different ways you
know the way that something like say you
know The Exorcist was scary was that it
took place in a home that felt like it
could be the home of anybody viewing it
when you do something
like this you need to lean in hard on
the fact that this is wrong and this is
bad right off the bat because there's no
disguising it so you might as well lean
hard into it
and honestly I enjoy most of this I'll
mention what I didn't enjoy we'll get
there but it seemed very clear to me
that this was that this is a bit of a
loving setup but a bit of a parody of
you know the Hammer horror style and and
Gothic you know store horror
storytelling in general because it is so
on the the point at which I felt I could
safely label it parody was when the
character of Hector showed up you know
who's kind of living in he's he is you
know
ridiculously pale with these sunken eyes
and this washed out hair and these long
nails and it's and and the voice that
I'm not a vampire if that's what you
were afraid of it's it really rides that
line where it is so ridiculous you can't
help but laugh at it yet at the same
time I could still believe that that
performance would actually be given in a
gothic horror movie circa I don't know
1962 or something I could do I could
bias and that's and that's the that's
the best kind of parody the best kind of
pastiche is to have it be passable as
the thing you're kind of jabbing fun at
because if it's if it doesn't even look
like the thing you're making fun of that
you're just doing it wrong so and it
does actually get some genuine tension
out of some of its moments as well you
know the build-up to a lot of it
and and it's it's gone along pretty well
like it's not blowing me away but I'm
going I kind of do yes I feel like I'm
on this thing's wavelength right up
until I got to the ending and normally
I'd spoiler this I suppose I will
anyways I'll kind of mention it but it
you can't really spoil this ending
because it doesn't really have one it
just kind of stops it stops at the very
least a scene before this story
should have ended and I think I get what
they were trying to go for in terms of
where they cut it off but you need to be
telling a very specific kind of story to
get away with cutting off before the end
the way this cuts off before the end so
like an example of something that does
it well I've mentioned this before the
series finale well you know I won't
mention that because that'll be consider
spoilers this is spoilers too but it may
be it's something that I think most
people will have seen so the ending of
the gray um I love and someone
notoriously and this upsets some
audience members it ends right before
the Liam Neeson wolf fight that was in
all that you know the lead up to was in
the trailers it cuts to black custom
black and goes to credits right at the
end and it works there because the
matically what the story is doing
whether or not he wins that fight
doesn't matter what matters is that he
chose to fight instead of just lay down
and accept the inevitable that is what
is important the outcome of the fight is
not nearly as important in terms of the
story that the film is telling this
doesn't have that kind of setup where
you can cut off before the end because
where it ultimately ended up wasn't the
point
this didn't pull that off so it didn't
earn ending before it had ended and that
that is sort of the fall down on this
cuz I was [ __ ] I'll just talk
specifics from here on out since I've
already talked about the ending so you
know more spoilers I guess I was digging
pretty much all the rest of it there
were a lot of neat little touches that I
liked I really liked the the friend the
goth teenage friend and the twist of her
being involved with the with the sort of
cult thing that was going on that worked
for me especially since like it wasn't a
complete he'll turn on her character
from what little you know we spent a
little time we spent with her I under I
felt like I understood her character
well enough to oh no this makes sense so
it didn't it didn't have the usual
problem that oh they were
usually has which is that the suddenly
you don't know them as a character
anymore it's like no this makes sense
this is consistent I dug that there was
a loo there was one little woman I loved
which was when the sister gets hit with
the taser gun and you know she's up
against the wall and like right before
she sells outlaw she just kind of just
it's just this quick little but I'm like
you enjoyed that a little bit didn't yet
and it's touches like that that I
actually really enjoy and there is a
creepiness to and I think the moment of
you know wait his hands are tied who
rang the bell that was a good moment and
I think the time II of that was planned
well so I really I was digging this
again I wasn't like blown away by it but
I was digging this I was having fun with
it until just failed to end I don't I
don't know why I don't know why they
thought that was the place to end like I
guess another episode from the same
series sardines kind of feels like it
maybe it ends before the ending because
we don't know whether or not that
character actually lights the fire but
again that we don't need to know that
what's important is realizing who he is
and what and how damaged he is and by
whom what his final choice to do about
that does not actually matter as far as
Revelations go and the abilities this
doesn't even end on a revelation it just
ends on something that had been built up
to for like the last ten minutes before
that thing that it was built up to
actually happened it's really it's weird
I I don't know what they were going for
with just cutting it off at the end like
that there isn't much more to say about
it beyond that so I guess what I'll do
wrapping up here is I quickly give my
ranking for the first six episodes of
this show so my favorite episode easily
was sardines the very first episode of
this season I really enjoyed that that
was
super well-structured just really
intelligently put together second
favorite episode would be Tom and Jerry
which was the third episode after that
it would be the understudy which I know
a lot of people don't seem to like that
much but I enjoyed because I'm a sucker
for what I feel is fairly well done
backstage in your depiction of actors
then I'll put the harrowing after that
and then at Fir as frustrating as my
issues were with it I would put a quiet
night in next because I do think
last-gasp has to go at the bottom just
for the laziness of it like the initial
premise is interesting enough but then
what it does is the laziest possible
option with that premise while I did not
like a quiet night in it at least had a
little bit more ambition if only from
the gimmick of it being a nearly silent
episode so there you go in any case I
think that'll that'll wrap it up and as
I said this will be the last inside
number 9 review that I'm planning like I
said I may or may not come back and talk
about specific episodes if and when I
get to them if they if they make me feel
like I really need to talk about it
we'll see but for now that's gonna be it
folks so what were your thoughts on the
harrowing how would you rank the
entirety of series 1 or your thoughts on
the show in general whatever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all that
stuff to do you know what it is there's
buttons and links and stuff I have a
patreon and there's a bunch of other
things as well if you care you can check
it out down in the description and
remember folks you are the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]